Jessica Kilian wollte immer beides nahe
an den Patienten sein aber auch eine
akademische Ausbildung absolvieren nun
leitet die 26-Jährige im ST Josefs
Hospital in Wiesbaden die
Intensivstation als sogenannte advanc
practice nur eine Ausnahme denn für
qualifizierte Kräfte wie sie gibt es
bislang nur wenig
Einsatzmöglichkeiten die Skepsis
gegenüber den akademisier Pflegenden ist
dann immer so die Frage und wann
kündigst du wann gehst du weg aus dem
Krankenhaus und meine Antwort war immer
gar nicht also ich plane es nicht und
ich habe es auch nicht vor und möchte
mich auch hier weiterhin entwickeln und
die Praxis verbessern Jessica Kilian
pflegt und versorgt nicht nur Patienten
sondern ist auch für die Organisation
und die versorgungsabläufe auf der
Station verantwortlich doch bisher sind
Pflegekräfte mit ihrer
Zusatzqualifikation sehr selten es gibt
einfach keine verpflichtenden Maßnahmen
keine gesetzgeberischen Maßnahmen keine
Maßnahmen die vor das Vorhandensein an
der solchen Advan practice nurse oder
auch Bachelor Pflegekräften vorsehen um
darüber z.B patientensteuerung
vorzunehmen und darüber die Pflege zu
verbessern das heißt viele die jetzt
insbesondere Praxis bezogen in der
Pflege studieren studieren momentan
leider leider in die
Ungewissheit eine Aufwertung des
Berufsstandes z.B durch ein Studium
fordert der Deutsche Pflegerat schon
lange ich bin jetzt seit 21 Präsidentin
des Deutschen pflegerates und
ich gucke in die Papiere von vor 20
Jahren und wir hatten dieselben
Forderungen in der damaligen Zeit
1918 hat in in USA der erste Studiengang
für die pfleg eröffnet es war vor 100
Jahren 2020 haben wir es in Deutschland
getan wir sind 100 Jahre
zurück jetzt soll alles besser werden im
Bundesgesundheitsministerium planen Sie
ein Gesetz das verkündet
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach für viele überraschend vor d
Monaten auf dem deutschen
Pflegetag wir bereiten ein Gesetz vor
das ist auch noch nichts öffentlich
bekannt geworden womit wir die Pflege
deutlich aufwerten wollen indem wir den
Spielraum was darf Pflege Anpassen an
das was Pflege kann Pflege kann derzeit
viel mehr als sie darf und diese Lücke
muss geschlossen werden inzwischen hat
der Bundesgesundheitsminister die
vorläufigen Eckpunkte für sein
sogenanntes
pflegekompetenzgesetz vorgelegt demnach
soll auch die akademische Ausbildung
gestärkt
werden wir wollen das Berufsbild der
Advanced practice nurs nach
internationalen Vorbildern etablieren
und werden perspektivisch entsprechende
Befugnisse in der Versorgung einführen
[Musik]
noch in diesem Jahr soll das Gesetz in
Kraft treten die Pflegewissenschaftlerin
Gabriele Meer begrüßt die Initiative
aber sie warnt vor zu hohen
[Musik]
Erwartungen also schnell damit ist
sicherlich nicht zu rechnen selbst wenn
das Gesetz in diesem Jahr noch
verabschiedet wird was ja auch sehr
sportlich wäre denn die Maßnahmen sind
sehr umfassend und Zielen insbesondere
auf Bildungsmaßnahmen und da müssen auch
zu z.B erstmal die richtigen
Infrastrukturen geschafft werden der
hochschulische Bereich muss ausgebaut
werden der Nachwuchs im
wissenschaftlichen Bereich muss
aufgebaut werden solange will
Intensivpfleger Kamil Albrecht nicht
warten bis sich endlich etwas ändert er
hat eine Marketingfirma gegründet sein
Ziel er möchte das Image der Pflege
verbessern
moin 12 Jahre war er im Krankenhaus im
Schichtdienst diese Erfahrungen aus der
Praxis möchte er jetzt jetzt nutzen auf
der Intensivstation arbeitet Kamil
Albrecht nur noch in Teilzeit
zusammengefasst war für mich eigentlich
relativ früh auch klar dass irgendwas an
dem standing und an der Wertschätzung
dieses Pflegeberufs nicht ganz stimmt
und das war auch sehr zügig mein Grund
warum ich von der frontarbeit in das
Marketing und in meine Agentur
reingewechselt bin Personalnotstand
schlechte Bezahlung Pflege am Limit
deswegen entwickelt er jetzt Kampagnen
sowie Strategien für Pflegeunternehmen
und ihre Angestellten organisiert
Veranstaltungen gestaltet Broschüren
Kamil Albrecht möchte dass seine
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ihre Interessen
künftig selbstbewusster vertreten für
mich ist also extrem wichtig dass der
Alltag anders funktioniert dass die
Expertise der Pflege auch wahrgenommen
wird eingefefordert wird in jeder Visite
in jedem Dienst damit die Pflege von
sich aus auch merkt okay ich bin hier
was wert und ich werde auch wirklich
wahrgenommen auch in der Uniklinik
Darmstadt kämpfen sie um ihr
Pflegepersonal Ninja Welli ist 38 Jahre
und noch begeistert sie ihr Beruf trotz
Schichtarbeit auf der
Intensivstation Schichtdienst ist schwer
für uns das ist nicht gesund das ist
allen glaube ich klar K ich würde mir
wünschen jeden Tag von 8 bis 4 arbeiten
zu können ohne Wochenenden und da immer
frei zu haben und keine Nachtdienste das
wäre natürlich toll aber das ist halt
nicht realistisch die Patienten liegen
ja trotzdem da in der Uniklinik
versuchen Sie Hände ringend auf den
Mangel zu reagieren um die Versorgung zu
gewährleisten mit leasingkräften
ausländischem Pflegepersonal flexiblen
Arbeitszeiten die Klinik ist für 1,2
Millionen Menschen zuständig ein
sogenannter
Maximalversorger das funktioniere aber
nur wenn die Belange der Pflege
berücksichtigt werden mE Pflegedirektor
Michele tinho
pflegerische Handlung ist mehr als nur
satt sauber und trocken halten
sondern es ist eine hochkomplexe
eigenständige Aufgabe die in dem
Gesundheitssystem heute noch gar nicht
abgebildet ist mm und zusätzlich im
politischen System auch überhaupt gar
nicht an den entscheidungstischen
verankert ist und das ist meiner Meinung
nach
ein weiterer Kardinalfehler das heißt
Gesundheitsreformen ohne Beteiligung der
Pflege sind eigentlich bei krafttreten
zum schaln verurteilt wird das
pflegekompetenzgesetz daran etwas ändern
Skepsis bei der
Pflegeexpertin wir haben viele Gesetze
gehabt und viele stimulie akademische
Pflege zu fördern und erweiterte
Kompetenzen zu befördern die wurden in
den letzten Jahrzehnten nicht
wahrgenommen das ist also nicht das
Garant für die bahnbrechende Wende in
der Stärkung der Pflege und der Stärkung
der pflegekompetenz in Deutschland es
muss ja auch umgesetzt werden das
Gesetz auch für den Intensivpfleger
Kamil Albrecht ist klar Lauterbachs
Gesetz kann nur ein erster Schritt
sein der Pflegeberuf kann schlussendlich
wenn man das alles mal zusammenfasst
natürlich attraktiv werden das ist die
gute
Nachricht die Nachricht die dahinter
kommt und die Wahrheit ist aber auch
dass da noch ein schon noch ein Prozess
stattfinden muss der
teilzeitintensivpfleger würde sein
marketingbüro wohl wieder schließen wenn
sich die Verhältnisse im Krankenhaus
grundsätzlich verbessert haben aber nur
dann